[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la rentrée
là on
dans sa non non je m'appelle amalia et
je suis artiste damien marine travail
nuit sur ordinateur puis faible la
scénographie
mes enfants et fonda musique voilà et il
fait aussi il fait aussi des baisers aux
lianes si les objets dehors que vous
avez filmé on m'a proposé de devenir
présidente pas sapanet pour le jury
salue mais à la réunion
je pense que c'est mes origines
malgaches et le fait que je travaille
sur madagascar king fait que ce choix
était fait je suis très heureuse
[Musique]
j'ai pas de média privilégié
je fais plutôt la peinture la
photographie démontage et des
installations
j'aime bien le côté un petit peu
mystérieux je travaille beaucoup sur les
portraits mais j'ai tendance à démasquer
les portraits beaucoup parce que je
travaille sur des portraits de famille
et sur les masques aussi les des
identités le tombeau familial
tous étaient photo de 2 me badat fait
une famille que je connais que je
connais pas puisque je travaille ici en
france sur madagascar beaucoup et sur
cette famille et je que je les trouve
dans mon histoire et donc j'essaie des
gens que on en a parlé mais je les ai je
les connais pas en fait donc je les ai
un peu manipulé j'ai essayé de me les
approprier ces gens là à travers leurs
images leurs photos moitié femme moitié
animal c'est sympa au delà de l'image la
cession du papier qui se froissent donc
l'idée de nous dresser vraiment dans le
papier transparent fragile qui réagit à
l'encré de chine
rodez chine va tirer sur le papier ça va
faire des petits oui ça m'a froissé un
petit peu
[Musique]
ça c'est plutôt un lieu qui écrit lire
mon quotidien que près de chez moi
donc j'aime bien aussi jouer avec
les gens qui sont au fond des choses
dans le territoire où j'habite
ça me permet de planter quelques racines
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu viens
[Applaudissements]
célimène que je regarde la mort
l'ensemble est un prêt je rentre
à l'intérieur de l'oeuvre si on peut
dire et en fait je suis très sensible à
la matérialité de l'oeuvre par exemple
ça c'est des photos mais pour moi ça
n'est pas que des images donc je dirais
que l'art c'est la vie mais c'est une
vie qui est travaillée qui est mise en
valeur qui est qui et qui partageait
aussi c'est des choses qu'on partage
aussi avec avec les autres ça devient de
l'art peu à peu c'est pas quelque chose
qui sort de terre comme ça
[Musique]